and we saw the wood award winners so now
we got to dive into grammy fashion
because the carpet was lit joining me
now personal shopper celebrity stylist
of style savvy lindsay burns a local las
vegas we're so glad to have you on the
show thank you heather and we got to see
the shoes can we see the shoes guys
okay we'll try to pull out just so we
can see these fabulous shoes that
lindsey is wearing let's talk about
there we go look at those because what
did you say neon lucia is the color of
the season okay there you go style tips
now let's dive into some of the fashion
let's pull up who do we have first i
think chrissy teigen
sofia carson right there oh there we go
okay chrissy teigen there she's wearing
fuchsia
and this dress is um
it's large she looks like a cake topper
is that kind of the thing right now i
saw a lot of ball gowns last night there
were a lot of ball gowns a lot of
princess looks okay but there were also
the pair down looks that really popped
there's a lot of restrained glamour but
a lot of edgy stuff as well right so
grammys are a little bit of everything
not just old hollywood and you know um
so wheatie i know we have some some
pictures of her as well of course a
rapper and and and you said kind of the
color you just named it exactly it's
fuchsia
even justin bieber was wearing a fuchsia
hat
so that is something definitely and the
cutouts too those are still really
really popular this is very very popular
you'll see a lot of those throughout the
show
and
one thing to notice on the
uh skirt is it's a very high waist which
is a great look right now for anybody
from
seven to seventy the higher waist
sucks it kind of hides some of the stuff
nobody wants to see and share okay so
higher waist cutouts fuchsia olivia
rodrigo let's call this up because here
she is a grammy winner she's just 19
lindsay
she's wearing this very adult ensemble
but i noticed the choker kind of makes
it a little more age-appropriate it does
it does that's a vivian westwood dress
and it's got the pink sparkles that go
all the way down the front that match
the choker that she's wearing like you
said that makes it look a lot younger
but for a 19 year old she is so fashion
aware very really glamorous yeah
never misses fit well and it you know it
wasn't too crazy it was something that i
almost could see other people picking up
at the store if it existed yeah and that
corset look is also very big this year
the body conscious dress
the dress that
kind of
makes you feel a little bit more special
it's kind of like putting on high heels
okay you walk a little differently you
do you walk a little taller hi hold that
head up now we got to talk about the
guys because i saw justin bieber and i
was like what happened here what is he
wearing well the suit is um a little bit
large
but he was making a statement with that
uh thankfully his wife haley was wearing
something that was a little bit more uh
appropriate for the occasion
but he is wearing a fuchsia hat yeah
he's got the hat on i mean i don't know
if his head was cold or not because it
was 85 degrees yesterday but but yeah
this oversized suit and um
this is something that i saw a lot on
the gentleman i mean aside from trevor
noah who was dressed very nicely to
entertain the audience it seemed like
the entertainers themselves were wearing
these baggy baggy suits is that
something we're going to see more of
that is actually a kind of trend that's
going to inform what we see in the
future probably not this season but
maybe a season or two down the road
we're going to start seeing looser cuts
flowing pants not quite as much as on
the grammys of course yeah a little less
but
it's interesting to watch this and then
see what what happens two years down the
road and something you of course keep
your eyes on because you're styling
people here in the city yes i am
wonderful well lindsay thank you so much
for being here this morning
um and of course if you have any
questions for her you can always reach
out to her on her website but we
appreciate you there you go there's your
grammy wrap and your fashion john what
do you think oversized suit maybe a size
you know
three two large david byrne look i like
that i'll be once in a lifetime over
here i don't mind i'll dig up the 80s
it's all good